[Music]
money it's everywhere
but what happens when your bills get old
and need to be replaced by new ones that
means old cash needs to be destroyed
a lot of cash
this is not however the story of money
growing on trees but of trees
growing out of money
well more like vegetables
we are here at the federal reserve bank
in new orleans and this is where we
shred millions of dollars
my name is dean mortha i'm the lead
business analyst for cash services here
at the new orleans bed we are the
nation's bank our job is to make sure
that we have a supply of currency also
part of that is to ensure that we remove
unfit old dirty currency from
circulation so here on average we shred
about six million dollars in dirty money
every day
this could be for any number of reasons
it could be because the note has rips in
it holes and it tears in it
it could have tape on it it could have
graffiti written all over it we don't
want that note going back into
circulation if it has any sort of those
qualities will be shredded
what we used to do is take all of these
currency shreds and they would just wind
up as waste going to a landfill
now through a lot of work and effort we
finally figured out a way where we can
take these shreds and ultimately recycle
them
so all that green leaves the fed and
heads to a compost facility where it
turns into something quite useful
what you're looking at right now is 24
million dollars but the soil that it
creates will be priceless
my name is jonathan christian
we turn cash into soil
it is definitely one of our secret
ingredients
it's little in content but it's huge in
what it provides
[Music]
currency that's deemed unfit it's
brought to our facility at wood
materials
from there we go through a simple
composting process where we convert that
into a healthy soil
our compost is used primarily by urban
farmers in the greater new orleans area
one of these farmers is simon minash and
this is a million dollar farm
we are making fresh local food
accessible in new orleans
we've grown veggies herbs cucumbers
tomatoes and peppers
the vegetables we grow here are made out
of composted cash
it is very fulfilling to
be growing using a material that would
otherwise go to waste
one man's trash is another man's
treasure
and that's the story of how we grow
tomatoes
out of cash
[Music]
if you have money that's been damaged in
a fire in a flood that's been eaten by
insects or animals
we'll evaluate and determine how much is
there and reimburse you for it
[Music]
my name is eric walsh i'm the assistant
manager of the immunity currency
division
every year the melee currency division
receives about 23 000 cases people will
send money that's been somehow damaged
and re-reimbursed annually about 40
million dollars it's a free service the
government provides that we pay a dollar
in dollar out
we require 51 of the note present to pay
on it and that just protects us from
paying twice on the same note once we
determine the amount we will send a
treasury check for what we discovered
we're pretty low tech here so the tools
of the trade are scissors knives
scalpels glue and tape and maybe a pair
of tweezers
the most challenging cases are usually
cases that the money has gotten wet and
set for long periods of times and it
will actually petrify and be solid as a
brick
a lot of is the dog ate my money we get
hundreds of those cases a year
a lot of people will hide their money in
the oven and forget about it or they'll
get it wet and put in the microwave and
that will ignite the currency
our most infamous case took place in the
80s and what happened was a farmer lost
his wallet in the field and discovered
that his cow had eaten it and we always
encouraged the submitter to send in the
package as it is and the farmer sent in
the cow's stomach which we were able to
retrieve the wallet firm and reimburse
the farmer his currency
[Music]
our office consists of just under 20
people and we have 12 people that
examine and process the submissions and
they do roughly between one thousand two
thousand claims each a year
we do get an increased amount of cases
after a national disaster
over the past year between the
hurricanes and wildfires out in
california we've reimbursed over two
million dollars we're called upon when a
lot of people hit their low point so any
relief that you could provide someone
after they lost all their money in a
flood or after their house burned down
it's very rewarding
hopefully we're a service that you'll
never need to use but in case something
does happen we're here for you
[Music]
[Music]
let's say you're a cheese producer and
you need a loan because you want to buy
a tractor or food for your cows or
really just about anything there's a
bank in italy that will take your cheese
and give you cash this is the story of
three men and millions of dollars worth
of cheese
meat mouth
he's a cheese producer in the emiliano
region of italy he produces parmigiano
reggiano the so called king of cheese
[Music]
20 000 wheels holy cow that's a lot of
cheese
when mauro or another cheese producer in
this part of italy needs a loan they go
to credito emiliano a big italian bank
and like any bank credito emiliano needs
collateral for their loan
and to do that he talks to fausto ciao
is a special kind of cheese because it
needs to be aged for 18 to 36 months and
a wheel can be worth thousands of
dollars making it a safe long-term
investment for the bank
addiction
[Music]
traditionally
to be clear the bank doesn't store the
valuable cheese in its vaults next to
gold bars and stacks of cash they have a
special cheese warehouse down the road
filled with thousands and thousands of
wheels of cheese that's where roberto
comes in he's the general director of
the tagliate general warehouses that's
where credito emiliano stores their
cheese
roberto and his team take care of more
than 300 000 wheels of cheese that's
currently worth more than 160 million
euros
without proper care cheese could lose
its value
[Music]
finally
roberto sounds to me like the cow the
bank and the cheese are in good hands
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a billion dollars we think and
that billion dollars belongs to rj
rappaport and he's considered the king
of cash king of fake cash okay king of
fake cash
[Music]
my name is rich rj rappaport and i'm the
president of rjr props
just a few years ago actually it was
nine years ago oh sorry nine years ago
rjr props was born
it's a full-service prop house
but its specialty is cash
fake cash and there's only a few people
who can legally make it and rj is one of
them
we work with 50 cent kendrick lamar lil
wayne fat joe young dolph
and that's just to name a few rj's prop
money has been used in over 175 feature
films television shows and music videos
and he devoted three full years to
perfecting that crisp green paper we
call money
prop money
and we went down a long path in working
with the secret service and learning all
the laws to make sure that everyone that
uses it it will be legal for them and
it'll look fantastic but for those who
don't follow the rules
they could wind up in big trouble there
was a rash of arrests people were just
literally jailed because they were using
prop money that looked too real and i
said to myself i'm not going to touch
this unless i know i'm doing it legally
alongside the secret service rj created
two different styles of prop money one
that is printed on both sides and is
perfect for that classic bank robbery
scene
the other kind is so close to the real
deal it can only be printed on one side
otherwise it could end up in circulation
it's designed for the classic money shot
aka this the close-up it's a tough
business we all work hard in it and prop
money especially is not easy yeah sounds
like it thanks rj for keeping fake money
real
[Music]
open up your wallet you'd expect to find
ones tens twenties maybe even a hundo
the last thing you'd ever expect is a
tom also known as a two dollar bill
here's why
[Music]
it was 1862 the federal government had
just started printing its first paper
money the first and only denominations
were the one dollar and two dollar bills
and keep in mind at the time people were
making about fifteen dollars a month to
pay using a two dollar bill was a status
symbol only the wealthiest of americans
could afford and a lot of the time they
used them for under the table
transactions like political bribes
prostitutes and gambling
the tom ultimately got a bad rap and was
deemed unnecessary in 1966 the
government took a 10-year hiatus and
stopped printing those bad boys
but in 1976 the government gave them
another try this time classing them up a
bit issuing a special bicentennial bill
a little too classy some would argue
people began hiding them away as
collector's items leading to less bills
in circulation which brings us to
present day though rare toms are still
being printed and there are over a
billion in circulation most people keep
them as keepsakes though there is a
subculture of two dollar ambassadors who
are set on keeping the tom alive by
using them every chance they get so the
next time you're paying with cash go
ahead use a tom
[Music]
you